Pour les portes ouvertes?
- Oui.
- Rien n'est laissé au hasard
pour la journée portes ouvertes
au Collège militaire roy
- Bienvenue au Collège royal
militaire de Saint-Jean!
- On ne veut pas manquer
l'occasion de fairesisisisisisis
des potentielles recrues.
- Si vous décidez vraiment
de venir ici...
- La plupart sont des jeunes
pour poursuivre leurs études.
Au milieu du groupe, il cececet
homme, qui attire l'attention.
DAVID GUITÉ
- Je suis en forme.
- David Guité est un décrocheur.
Il a fait carrrerere dans
la construction. Aujourd'hui,
il se sent prêt à s'asseoir sur
les bancs d'
- D'aller voir des sinistrés,
le saugegege de famille prises
dans des régions qui ont
pas d'aide. J'aimerais ça,
- C'est le genre de recrue qui
tombe à point pour la ministre
ANITA ANAND, ministre
de la Défense s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,sc
les feux de forêt, tout le monde
les jeunesplplplus vieux veulent
voir des opportunités.
- Ça, c'est vraiment notre
- La major-générale Lise Bourgon
est responsable des ressources
humaines dans les Forces armées.
C'est elle qui la mission
de regarnir les rangs.
LISE BOURGON, majore-générale
des Forces armées canadiennes
- Montrer aux Canadiens le rôle
domestiquement, mais aussi
internationalement. Quand
les temps où je me suis sentie
la plus fière, c'esananand
j'étais capable d'aider
les communautés, même si
des sacs de sable.
- L'armée dididienne a lancé
en 2010 l'opération LENTUS,
aux besoins de la population
canadienne lors de catastrophes
récemment lors du passage
de l'ouragan Fiona.
l'opération LANTUS a donné lieu
3 3 38 interventions,
dont 7 seulement en 2021.
BRUNO CHARBONNEAU, prof., S S Sn
- Moi, je suis rentré
au collège, effectivement,
au début des années 90.
Donc pour moi, l'argumi,i,i,i,i,
c'était l'idée du soldat
de la paix.
- Bruno Charbonneau est
maintenant promimimimimimimimim.
Selon lui, c'est la réponse
à la crise climatique qui doit
aujourd'hui faire partie
de l'argFoFoFoFoFoFoFoFoFoFoFoFn
à un nouveau programme
de baccalauréat, qui verra
le jour en 2024.
le fait qu'ils approuvent qu'on
construise ce programme- a a aui
reflète, je pense, les besoins
des Forces canadiennes tels
eux-mêmes.
- Des besoins qu s s se limitent
pas aux opérations en territoire
canadien.2021, l'OTAN
a annoncé qu'elle voulait être
l'organisation internationale
qui allait mener un peu,
définir l'agenda de  e e e e e -
là, le Canada a annoncé
la création d'être l'hôte
d'un centre d'excellenceTATATAT.
Si on met tout ça ensemble,
je pense qu'effectivement,
on pourrait repenser
la mission des Forces.
- La mission primordiale,
c'est de défendre le Canada.
- Le général à la retraite
Andrew Leslie a été chef d'état-
il a siégé comme député libéral
O O Ottawa. Il est sceptique fe
à ce virage.
retraite, ancien député libéral
- Le gouvernement des libéraux
sont des pacifistes.
des Forces.
Et le lelele ultime de l'armée
canadienne, comme on voit
aujourd'hui ce qui se passetetee
à battre contre un ennemi.
CeCeCe serait avant et aprèsaca.
- Da l l lui, devra se battre
contre un autre genre d'ennemi
Qu'est-ce qui te fait le plus
ururur?
- C'est les études.
Je ne pensais pas que
j'arrêterai pas. Chaque rêve,
a a a des défis. Ça peut pas
se faire aussi facile que ça.
- Ici Valérie Gamache,o-o-o-o-o,
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu